peu un peu
film entre man 2 n'est pas là par hasard
et notamment avec sa sortie au cinéma
situé après celles d'in fi nit hiwar
mais qui se passe dans l'histoire
chronologiquement avant tout est prévu
marvel ne rigole pas du tout là dessus
les réponses et les mystères sont là et
il va falloir réfléchir pour découvrir
ce que nous prépare à 22h04 par rapport
à août man et la guêpe
je ne vous cache pas que ce qui va nous
intéresser aujourd'hui surtout la scène
post générique de ce dernier quand le
film est un origin story la scène post
générique du film sera toujours en
rapport avec le prochain film du héros
pensons par exemple à antoine un kit is
entre man 2 et civil war car il
apparaîtra dedans d'où les célèbres
nanana reviendra entre man 2 fait partie
de l'origine story du héros ant man soit
scott langue donc la scène post
générique est en rapport avec le futur
de othman et sa prochaine apparition
c'est logique ortman 3 n'est pas prévu
pour le moment je précise sûr pour le
moment tout ce que nous savons et qu'il
apparaîtra dans avengers 4 donc cette
scène post générique est en rapport avec
ce film c'est sûr enfin bref maintenant
que le contexte est posée intéressons
nous aux contenus et donc aux théories
hante man se retrouve projeté dans le
champ quantique pour en extraire de
l'énergie permettant de soigner
définitivement havas alias ghost
cependant au moment du retour de scott
dans le monde réel janet en europe sont
tous les trois disparus duo claquement
de doigts de notre ami thanos scott se
retrouvent donc enfermé dans la
dimension quantique
mais déjà pour combien de temps
apparemment d'après plusieurs sources et
rumeurs avengers 4 se déroulerait
quelques années plus tard une finity
voir donc il se pourrait qu antoine
reste dans la dimension quelques années
c'est une supposition
ce qui fait réfléchir par rapport à
cette durée dans la dimension et que
scott marche dans les traces de djanet
il se retrouve enfermé dans cette
dimension et on sait pour combien de
temps suite à ces 30 années dans la
dimension quantique janet s'est vu être
modifiées être évoluer comme elle la
firme qu'elle s'est adapté à la
dimension
c'est d'ailleurs pour ceux ci qu'elle
possède désormais des pouvoirs un petit
peu télékinésiques comme charles xavier
pour mieux s'en rapprocher si scott se
doit nous rester dans la dimension
pendant un certain temps il se peut que
ce dernier voit en quelque sorte sa
condition évolué on ne sait à quelle
échelle nous en avons déjà un petit peu
la preuve avec le fait que scott est le
seul à avoir pu entrer en contact
télépathiquement avec janet car il était
allé dans la dimension quantique pour
continuer après avoir lu bon nombre de
vos commentaires et échanger avec
certains il est vrai qu'une phrase de
djanet est très importante et prête à
réflexion
c'est bien évidemment celle ci évite
d'approcher les vortex temporel où nous
ne pourrons plus tôt ramener elle dit ça
en quelque sorte
scott n'est pas du genre à rester sur
place et attendre s'il est enfermé dans
la dimension il est quasiment sûr à 100%
qu'un vortex temporel et sa seule porte
de sortie
plusieurs rumeurs ou autres clichés du
tournage d'avengers 4 suppose que les
avengers remonter dans le temps pour
pouvoir contrer la noce
on le remarque par le biais des anciens
costumes portés par ces derniers ai-je
besoin de vous faire un dessin pour lier
ce que je viens de vous dire
depuis nous supposons que la dimension
quantique sera très présente dans le
futur et la phase 4 de marvel pourrait
se tourner plus vers le côté galactique
et les dimensions amené le voyage dans
le temps les dimensions permettrait
d'ouvrir à énormément de portes pour le
futur de la saga et surtout créé de la
cohérence avec ceux qui ne nous est pas
encore connue mais bref là n'est pas la
question si le vortex temporel et
mentionner c'est que quand man va
l'emprunter et donc créé le premier
voyage dans le temps de la série
repenser aux premiers films ou hank
explique le phénomène de choc antique
ascot
bizarrement ce dernier accède à la fin
du film
rien n'est laissé au hasard si on
souhaite aller encore plus loin on peut
imaginer quand man après avoir traversé
importe ex temporel puissent se
retrouver dans un futur dans lequel
stark captain america et les autres ont
perdu tout espoir de sauver les victimes
du gant de l'infini
et après ce retour d'antoine et sa
collaboration avec tony
il serait peut-être possible pour eux de
trouver un moyen de traverser le temps
cette fois tous ensemble avec bien
entendu un plan très solide en tête
bien évidemment la question que soulève
ce voyage c'est surtout qu'ils sont les
passagers et quand et comment peut-on
inclure captain marvel dans l'équation
dans le scénario si ces pouvoirs sont
liés de près ou de loin au monde
quantique
elle pourrait peut-être finalement être
la réelle clés permettant
l'aboutissement de cette mission et
après tout nick fury avait peut-être le
moyen d'avertir captain marvel peu
importe la temporalité dans laquelle
elle se trouve et ce grâce au boîtier
visible dans la scène post générique du
film
il n'est donc pas à exclure qu'une
technologie en lien avec le chant conti
que puisse finalement existé mais bon je
m'égare
toutefois je tiens tout de même à
signaler qu'à la base entre mâles est le
véritable leader des avengers dans les
premiers comics avengers 4 pourrait
alors en quelque sorte lui rendre
honneur en le mettant au centre de
l'intrigué comme personnage important
qui permettra à nos héros d'inverser la
donne d'ailleurs ceci expliquerait les
photos de tournage d'avengers 4 de scott
en compagnie de stark et captain america
peut-être sont-ils en possession d'une
sorte de régulateur pour accéder au
chant quantique ou du moins quelque
chose pour manipuler le temps bref les
théories sont encore très présentes des
liens pourraient être aussi créé par
rapport à captain marvel comment faire
venir un personnage des années 90 sans
la faire vieillir de 30 ans on ne sait
encore rien de spécial sur le film mais
les voyages dans le temps pourrait être
une solution surtout qu'apparemment les
pouvoirs de la jeune héroïne posséderait
des liens avec la dimension quantique
d'après les rumeurs il est même possible
d'aller plus loin si vous avez l'esprit
tordu comme moi imaginez que strange
oui oui docteur strange puisse rejoindre
nos héros
si jamais le snap de thanos et envoyait
la moitié de l'existence dans la pierre
de l'âme comme le déclare de nombreux
théoriciens il se pourrait même que
strange puisse se libérer de sa prison
en voyageant à travers les réalités
grâce à ses pouvoirs de sorciers qui
rappelant le lui d'un accès également à
la dimension quantique
après tout les héros disparus ont été
emportées avec leurs vêtements ainsi que
leurs accessoires
strange pourrait alors être toujours
équipé de son anneau
mais bon c'est c'est farfelu est assez
what the fuck mais que voulez-vous
n'oublions pas que ce ne sont que des
théories personnellement je ne suis pas
trop d'accord avec ceux ci bien que tout
reste possible les frères russo avaient
affirmé que seule gamme aura était
enfermée dans la pierre de l'âme mais il
se peut toujours qu'ils aient menti pour
brouiller les pistes
doctor strange aura un grand rôle aussi
même le picsou magazine le confirme
mdr peut-être que strange nous la ferai
alaric et marty avec un autre strange
provenant de la dimension c137
remplaçant celui déjà mort bon allez
j'arrête mes conneries je pense vous
avoir déjà énormément bassiner avec
doctor strange
peu importe si vous avez apprécié ou non
en semaines et la guêpe ce film apporte
des réponses implicite et d'autres
mystères à théoriser avengers 4 sera
grand et surtout sera le point final de
la phase iii avec la probable mort de
thanos mais des héros mourront des pages
se tourneront mais d'autres chapitres
vont s'écrire évidemment de nombreuses
portes vont s'ouvrir pour la phase iv et
antoine pourrait bien être celui qui va
les ouvrir je remercie ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo vous pouvez me
soutenir via mon ultime gratuitement en
regardant quelques pubs mais le meilleur
moyen de mai des restes de s'abonner et
de me suivre sur twitter
n'hésitez pas à voir la chaîne d'aero
monde double maléfique de la dimension y
891 que le 'lion' woerth soit avec vous
cet argot rock et dire au cev
l'explorateur d'univers pour vous servir
[Musique]